hi I'm Florence Pugh and I play Amy hi
I'm Eliza Scanlon I play Beth hi I'm
Saoirse Ronan I play Joe and we are at
BuzzFeed today to take the which Little
Women character are you quiz first how
would your BFFs describe you option
number one imaginative option number two
tough option number three loyal option
of the fourth practical option number
Five's
energetic and option number six it's
really hot yeah I think energetic I
think I would be described as passionate
I'm thinking which I'm the same I think
you guys have such nice ons as I do
passionate energetic is a great answer
that's just like the loud choose a
classic novel Wuthering Heights by Emily
brontë our tequila Mockingbird by Harper
Lee Alice in Wonderland by Lewis Carroll
Jane Eyre by Charlotte Bronte Pride and
Prejudice Jane Austen Of Mice and Men by
John Steinbeck one day to kill a
mockingbird because I'm in it because
you're in it you're in - come on Briggs
you have to say you Monica say that I
yes I am naughty
so you're picking two killer Malcolm yes
I am I can have you picked already
you've moved on you're so energetic
Alice in Wonderland
no I'm to kill a mockingbird as what I
like - oh well darn Heights yeah
definitely
pick a song to sing at karaoke baby one
more time
Oh party in the US isn't it ironic and
come on Eileen I think come on Eileen I
have connections to ironic as well
because in my first film that I ever did
I have to sing ironic Oh
but I like party in the USA I also love
I wanna dance with some of it yeah I'm
gonna pick come on Eileen because me too
Eileen's my main attacking everyone over
the same in America but in the UK and
Ireland oh yeah yeah yeah yeah me and my
siblings put this on and like without a
second loss we just scream the entire
song cool it's just like guys like the
dad in the corner he's like alright
buddy already done it Queen because okay
choose a photo Timothy
choose a photo of Timothy challenege oh
I might do purple purple jacket I love
the last one year okay the last one was
terrific
I liked the wave it was quite friendly
right free cheese on it
[Laughter]
she's a Meryl Streep movie Oh Mamma Mia
here I go again the next one The Devil
Wears Prada yeah
Sophie's Choice Julie and Julia crema
the screamer it's complicated devil was
product she is come on
probably Sophie's Choice I love creminis
there was so much from her things that
she did you know in Little Women that I
was like this is just run recently back
in the day hey make Miranda Priestly
should have had Michael the poodle yeah
Michael Mike I know these choice and
finally pick something important from
the
women Wow so Joe's novel The Pickwick
Club Christmas Day Ami's paintings Meg's
wedding or Betty's piano pick something
important well they're okay well little
women wouldn't be little wind because
Jose Nobile
yeah but then Christmas Day is the first
thing that happens but then the P quick
Club is weird like the girls and the boy
in love together
mm-hmm max wedding is when we let go of
one from the group that's a sad day
that's a sad day and Amy's paintings are
nicer without young perusal maybe I
should just take a rest okay will you do
best piano you just Jose Nobile
yeah okay let's be selfish Jim why guys
I got a meme on your personality matches
Amy oh okay like Beth you are a
protector you take a little while to
open up to new people once you do they
become your friend for I show you do we
want to know about the best gift to give
it 2019 that's another link we could go
on that one one of them says a shoe
stand for all your slippers something
that every woman answered a bunch of
Secrets about life is a celeb and it's
only 16 reactions well guess in Aaron
taylor-johnson and his big Johnson no
will guess which high school clique you
belong to based on the cafeteria food
you choose this has been a very
enlightening experience I think been a
lot of fun like a lot about ourselves
and you should totally go and watch this
film on the 25th of December and figure
out which sister you are take the quiz
look up me Meg I'm gonna eat you
yeah I wish I got Joe
[Music]